を張っ
[音楽]
ん
テンキーナー
[音楽]
と思ってたら夕方になってました肇社長です皆さん太陽の光て強くないんですかはいよ
の一つ良い目指すべきを対応があったかいんでこの太陽の光を使って今日はちょっと
バーベキューできればいいなと思ってこちらを準備いたしましたはいこちらです鏡です
太陽の光でこうやってきてこれで半差でうまいことカメラにぶつけたら徒明るい
鏡は光を反射
行けるのでこれ見えるかなでも太陽の光岡組に反射させてため返すとこういうふうに
ですね太陽の光を反射させることが出来ますこれがですね結構明るいんですよ
反射でもくしゃみが出て来ないからいいんですよ蘭子だらめっちゃきちゃったかな鏡
準備したんで手塚が皆が入ってか1回数えます
この時
当たり前のようだやはず目は思ってしまった
2位はせずね誰かあの根源の目標は鏡の反射を委託しているそのまま1点に反射してる
わけですよ
その日か旅行集めて1点集中させて兆候火力の光を作り出しあの光で木はヤキ2個
しようと思いますねちょっと本気で作ろうと思っていてめちゃくちゃ国上買ったんです
けどもう
いう形で比較で遠足で鏡出す時間でもう日が暮れたらと思っ
対9でちょっと急ぎます
[音楽]
プッシュん
う食べの奥10個だと思います打ったけど60個の鏡を追尾しました
今1点にまとめてはいをの光るなるべくまとめて過電流[ __ ]でにしたいと思います
もう太陽が沈みそうなんで地肌いただきます
動くよね確か
こういうことで amazon の a に2つ集めましょう
[音楽]
できましたあーやばいめっちゃ待ってここらへんもたようんや手芸でも
あついあつい
天津や内面めぐ java 8の無理だって言うけどそこの生ニックを焼き肉にして
いこうと思います
ようとしたんですけど
無理だたぶん無理だたぶん寝たいよなんてここの日まで全然光ってるんだけどこれども
太陽落ち着いて光ってないんですよね
太陽動くからねどんどん形が変わっていっちゃういっ跳躍だけ焼いてありますよねあ
ために開けないんだろうなぁ
めっちゃあったかくあるんですけど
止めてか牛肉ってさーじゅに来てくれるのかなぁこのまま
やばい変化がないし光がどんどん広がってくれますね
[音楽]
術たいです無理だったはい太陽が沈んでしまい光もかなり分散しちゃいましたね
失敗だった以前で失敗しましたねまた花夕方スタートっていうのがまず失敗だしー
ってかもそこだけかもしれないな客になら遊学じゃなかったらワンチャンイケてたん
じゃねって思ったし
は館で何か体感的にもうちょっと肩身増やしてもいいかなって思いました
みんな覚えておくんなよなから失敗と反省を繰り返し
良くなっていく
トライ後ペラぬ
次回は必ず事項たぜ
def
うねー
[音楽]
me
あっはぁ